اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره نقلت صحيفه
جورنال عن مسؤولينا انه مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جيك سوليفان اجرى محادثات
سريه مع كبار المساعديه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمر بوتين في محاوله للحد من مخاطر
نشوب صراع او ساعه حول اوكرانيا ولتحضير
موسكو من محبه اللجوء بوتل للسلاح النووي
او البيولوجي
نقلته بكلته ريان ووفستيا الروسيه النقوات
صورا لعمليات ينفذها مسلحو فاجنر
في المجموعه ان قوته سيطرت على بلدتين
ملاسقتين للمدينه من جهه الجنوب وان الجيش
الاوكرانيه يحاول صده هجماتهم
قال نائب رئيس المجلس الاقليمي في خيرسون
يوري سبوليسكي من القوات الروسيه لا تغادر
خيرسون في الوقت الحالي وعلينا نائب محاكم
مقاطعه خرسنا المهوال لروسيا كيريل ستريم
ان القوات المسلحه لوكرانيه تحصد دبابات
وعربات مدرعه باعداد كبيره على محور خرسون
حضر رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان جهات انقل انها تحاول
الاختباء خلف الجيش من اجل العوده الى
الحياه السياسيه وطلب البرهان حزب المؤتمر
الوطني المنحل والحركه الاسلاميه بالكف عن
استغلال الجيش الشاسيه
من جهته قبل القيادي وبالحركه الاسلاميه
امين حسن عمر للجزيره ان فزاعه الانقلاب
لم تعد تخيفه احدا لان السودان لن ينجح
فيه انقلاب يقوده اسلاميون او بحثيون او
شيوعيون بحسب تعبيره
انقلاب المدني تحت عنوان تسويه ثانيه
مدعومه من الخارج لن ينجح الا اذا ايد هذه
التسويه السواد الاعظم من السودانيين
غادر الزعيم وحزبين صافي المعارض عمران
خاننا للمستشفى الى منزله في لاهور بعد
ثلاثه ايام من محاوله اغتياله ورحب عمران
انه بدعوه رئيس الحكومه الشريف لتشكيل
لجنه قضائيه للنظر في الحادثه لكنه اشتراط
استقاله شريف نفسه ووزير الداخليه
وضابط في الاستخبارات كي تتمكن اللجنه من
العمل بشكل مستقل على حد قوله
في غضون ذلك تبحث الحكومه الباكستانيه في
الخيارات القانونيه الممكنه خان بسبب
اتهامه مسؤولين الكبارا بالتخطيط
الاختياله واعتقلت السلطات وعشرات من مؤيد
عمران خلال مشاركتهم في وقفات تضامنيه معه
شكرا على متابعه المدرس لما كنتم طاب
توقعاتكم بكل
[موسيقى]